l'alarmé a retenti à nouveau ce matin à
val d'isère 24 heures après la
catastrophe il ne s'est pas passé en
fait une heure ce matin sans une
nouvelle avalanche 5 fois au moins la
route de bourg saint maurice à val
d'isère a été coupées par des coulées de
neige
plus grave encore pendant une heure en
fin de matinée on a craint le pire c'est
soit ça se passait dans la vallée cela
se passait à bourg-saint-maurice là une
très grosse avalanche avait emporté en
était certain
plusieurs dizaines de voitures après en
cas d'ouvriers où se trouve sur cette
carte bourg saint maurice et avec
albertville les deux points de repli
pour les sauveteurs et pour les blessés
de la catastrophe d'hier donc à
bourg-saint-maurice ce matin à 11h15
l'avalanche emportent des voitures après
dix deux heures de recherches on a pu
vérifier qu'il n'y avait pas un seul
occupant dans ses voitures pour
l'excellente raison que la route de
bourg saint maurice à val d'isère est
entièrement interdite à la circulation
depuis hier pas même monsieur marcellin
ministre de l'intérieur qu'accompagnait
monsieur committee qu'il est arrivé hier
soir dans la station de val d'isère
monsieur martial lui-même n'a pas réussi
à prendre la route pour revenir ce matin
assister au conseil des ministres
peut-être pourra-t-il partir ce soir la
neige continue de tomber en rafales
depuis maintenant quarante heures sur la
station de val d'isère le maire de la
ville a ordonné ce matin par nécessité
de nouvelles évacuations
c'est à dire qu'il a voulu regrouper
dans les hôtels et les immeubles du
centre de la ville
les occupants des chalets des immeubles
ou des hôtels isolé qui lui paraissent
courir maintenant beaucoup trop de
danger du fait de l'abondance de la
neige
le bilan il est tout de même moins élevé
que celui qu'on pouvait craindre hier
soir officiellement il y a maintenant 39
morts
60 blessés et surtout il n'y a plus et
26 disparus dont nous vous parlions
d'après le bilan officiel
hier soir c'est 26 disparus semble-t-il
ont été retrouvés encore qu'ils courent
pas mal de rumeurs à ce sujet ce matin
encore les mêmes questions évidemment se
repose cette avalanche était-elle
prévisible
toutes les mesures de sécurité étaient
telles prises
d'autre part devait-on laisser
construire ce chalet de l'ucp à à
l'endroit où intervenus cette avalanche
et c'est pour répondre à toutes ces
questions
je vous propose des documents quelques
minutes après la catastrophe hier matin
les envoyés spéciaux d'information
première josé le delliou michèle causse
se trouvait sur place en effet depuis
trois jours j'osais le delliou tournait
sur ce sujet des avalanches il tournait
à tignes toujours isolées d'ailleurs je
signale en passant dix mille personnes
sont bloquées maintenant depuis une
semaine dans la station de tignes tout
proche de val d'isère donc j'osais le
delliou tournait sur ce sujet des
avalanches aussitôt prévenus
il s'est précipité et ce sont ces
documents que vous allez voir maintenant
voici donc il hier matin à 10h ou un peu
avant 10 heures le chalet de l'ucp à
tous sont les travail de sondage vous
voyez au coude à coude les sauveteurs
cherchent dans cette masse de neige vous
voyez la voiture vous donne une idée de
la hauteur de la nage en dégage une à
une les voitures à ce moment là on ne
sait pas que la plupart des voitures
sont vides
sous la poussée de la neige les
portières ont cédé on est obligé de
chercher dans la neige lors si les
occupants n'ont pas été éjecté enseveli
dans le même temps dans ce chalet que
vous voyez au fond il faut continuer les
fouilles dégager la neige à l'appel
sortir à noël est blessé je vous
rappelle pierre il y avait tant de
blessés pour les premiers sauveteurs
qu'on se contentait de leur dégager la
tête pour leur permettre de respirer
soixante blessés ainsi dégagé
transporter ensuite dans la vallée à
l'hôpital de bourg-saint-maurice où à
l'hôpital d'albertville sur ces 60
blessés heureusement quatre ou cinq pas
plus ce sont encore ce matin dans un
état stable
les autres des scellements commotionné
ces sauveteurs que vous venez de voir
c'était bien sûr comme toujours les
guides les pisteurs de la station de val
d'isère il y avait là aussi une
compagnie de chasseurs alpins qui se
trouvait à l'entraînement il y avait là
aussi certain nombre de sauveteurs
bénévoles
quand la sirène a sonné mais nous sommes
précipités ici avec des peintres et
justement les repères vous aviez
suffisamment de matériel veut il oscille
entre les amants nombreux au contraire
le monde y avait presque tout le monde
se génère est en fait il y avait
suffisamment de man sur place 5 devis
rapidement les bénévoles aussi revu sur
tout le monde est arrivé de prestations
au nucléaire était horrible cet été
difficile de pouvoir sortir s'est joint
à l'entente allait trouver puisqu'il
était au fond mais l'avalanche est elle
allée jusqu'au plafond avant les bleus
c'est au fond il a fallu dégager par les
fenêtres si nous trouvons il est en
forme et c'est comme cm de neige au
dessus de nous ayé c'est injuste est
remplie jusqu'aux vent allait commencer
à dégager les fenêtres pour faire
pouvoir déjà revenir à l'intérieur c'est
le suivant les cloisons les fenêtres ici
qui ont été défoncées par l'avalanche
mais oui c'est ça oui les gens donc été
poussé les camps de redon sur les murs
et puis c'est à ras le sol croyez alors
c'est pour ça qu'on a mais quand même
j'ai pas certain temps a prouvé
l'économie combien avez vous mis de
temps pour dégager complètement cette
pièce à pièce environ deux heures après
le
ce qui est dramatique c'est que tous les
pensionnaires de l'ucv à se trouvait
justement dans cette pièce qui est le
réfectoire et c'est ça et une demi-heure
avant il omet leurs chants travailler
cinq ou dix minutes avant s'en est fallu
de 5 ou 10 minutes ça il venait juste
d'arriver à gaza
je vous mettrais
il m'a félicité pour mon gars tu connais
le débat roi ici même pas l'endroit pour
s'abriter regarde
d'où vous avez été sur place le premier
pratiquement ce matin je vous avais
arrivé à 8h au cirano est sonné qu'avez
vous pu faire des crs et bien
immédiatement avec l'open lançons nous
avons essayé de dégager et les victimes
qui appelait au secours nous d'avancer
le plus rapidement possible
immédiatement je peux dire que nous
avons eu à peu près une centaine de
sauveteurs sur place
cette avalanche était absolument
imprévisible et nous avons été
absolument absolument 4 catastrophé on
ne s'attendait pas à une catastrophe de
cette importance étape septembre la la
commission de sécurité devait se réunir
à 8h15 mais pour prendre les
dispositions sur la route et non pas du
tout dans ce secteur qui à notre avis il
n'est pas n'était pas du tout dangereux
et c'est la tempête de cette nuit qui a
cumulé une grosse masse de neige dans un
lieu qui s'appelle le dos mais qui à
notre avis ne voulais pas partir ça
n'est jamais arrivé une avalanche à cet
endroit
d'autres témoignages euse doit préciser
d'ailleurs que monsieur joue clooney de
voir que les gays la station de val
d'isère puisqu'il est le chef des pistes
de val d'isère le chef
les services de sécurité en quelque
sorte de cette situation d'autres
témoignages encore d'autres témoignages
peut être encore plus émouvant il s'agit
en fait témoignages des rescapés que
vous avez vue dégagée tout à l'heure les
stagiaires de l'ucp à ce sont 39 de
leurs amis de leurs camarades qui sont
restés prisonniers de cette terrible
avalanche de survivants du centre de
plein air à ce que pouvait bien ce qui
s'est passé exactement ce qui s'est
passé lors du petit déjeuner
nous étions rassemblés vers 8h15 une
avalanche est arrivé du côté nord et a
complètement balayé le réfectoire mort
où nous dit
une centaine à peu près toute la neige
est arrivée du côté de la baie vitrée
elle complètement démoli ce pan de mur
et a emmené on savait un certain nombre
de personnes et pas vous comment vous
êtes vous retrouvée pour la complètement
ensevelis c'est pas tellement dans
combien de temps je suis resté semaine
et je retiens c'est qu'au bout d'un
certain temps j'ai senti quand même
qu'on dégage à mes pieds
et là j'ai repris espoir je me suis
retrouvée de l'autre bâtiment le camp de
base du cpa où les premiers soins a été
donnée à ce que vous avez pensé que
c'était une avalanche qui au début non
mais une fois que j'étais sous la neige
n'est pas une connaissance et j'ai
compris vite nous aurons été blessé à la
main oui j'ai reçu et vite
juste un petit procédure il ya d'abord
eu la neige qui est tombée un cas
l'impression que tomber du toit
voilà je me suis levé pour garder à ce
moment là il ya l'avalanche qui arrivait
j'ai vu le jugez-vous le fanage j'étais
un peu à peu par la porte mais je
prépare le temps le temps de pâques on
trouve ton cas peut-être tous les bits
comme coach est plutôt bien sorti et que
vous est il arrivé exactement
disons que les seuls moments j'ai pas
grand chose sur le congé des prête-noms
car au train domine mais je viens casser
du tout qui vise à soutenir
sacha pas vous dire je m'en suis
retrouvé là
je rends licha nos docteurs ce soir dans
notre journal de 19h45 je pense que nous
pourrons vous montrer de nouveaux
documents grâce à nos envoyés spéciaux
je vous rappelle que même maintenant
brièvement la situation ce matin
val d'isere donc est toujours isolée
pour l'instant une seule caravane et
c'est une nouvelle de toute dernière
minute
parti à 11h30 de bourg saint maurice
tente de gagner la station de val
d'isère c'est d'une caravane funèbres
d'ailleurs parce qu'on y est il s'agit
de cinq ou six camionnettes qui emporte
les circuits et qui tentera de
redescendre cet après midi les corps des
39 victimes deuxième caravane possible
dès ce soir ou en tout cas demain cette
caravane tenterait de redescendre dans
la vallée
une partie des classes de neige des
occupants d'un certain nombre de cars
aussi bloqué contre leur gré depuis
plusieurs jours dans la station même et
qui doivent redescendre dans la vallée
je pense qu'il faut terminer sur un
dernier conseil pour tous ceux qui
pensent peut être rentré aujourd'hui des
sports d'hiver en effet il s'agit du
dernier jour des vacances scolaires de
mardi gras je crois qu'il faut de toute
façon respecter toutes les consignes de
sécurité données par les responsables
des stations où les responsables des
ponts et chaussées il n'y a pas de
problème sur vous dit de ne pas passer
parce qu'il ya danger d'avalanche c'est
qu'il y ait réellement danger j'en veux
pour preuve cette nationale 202 qui
descend de val d'isère et qui en
permanence depuis ce matin est coupé par
le très fort d'avalanche janvier guitare
les apps ne sont malheureusement pas la
seule région en france a souffert du
mauvais temps l'alsace et la champagne
ont connu au cours des dernières 24
heures des chutes de neige et de calan
d'inondations dans les vosges la station
du champ de feu est isolé et les 150
skieurs de cette station sont bloqués
depuis 24 heures en alsace et en
champagne on signale un peu partout une
recrudescence des inondations de
nombreuses routes et des voies ferrées
sont coupées par les eau coupée par les
eaux ou endommagées à la suite de
glissements de terrain
la météo demeure assez pessimiste
prévoyant pour ces deux régions de
nouvelles averses de pluie et de
nouvelles chutes de neige sur les
hauteurs un reportage de nos stations de
reims et de strasbourg dans le
département de l'aube les crues n'ont
pas encore atteint la cote dallaire
à troyes la mauvaise période est passée
mais les eaux de la seine et de l'aube
afflux maintenant sur nogent sur seine
où l'on s'attend à une montée très
sérieux tous les chemins transversaux de
la vallée sont coupées il en est de même
pour les routes nationales 373 et 440
dans la région d'epernay les crues de la
marne qui certaines années ont dépassé
un mètre semble aujourd'hui un peu moins
fort toutefois la peine d'aï célèbre
pour ses vignobles est submergé et hier
un habitant complètement isolée au
milieu des eaux a dû être secouru par
les sapeurs pompiers
l'entrée de la commune d'aïn et déjà
noyé et plusieurs cadres sont évidemment
inondées
pour l'heure les eaux son étal le ciel
assez dégagé ne laisse présumer aucune
précipitation
si cette situation se maintient il ya
peu de dangers redoutés dans le cas
contraire il faudra vraisemblablement
évacuer une partie de la population du
nord au sud de l'alsace des campagnes et
de nombreuses villes inondées offre un
spectacle de désolation dans les
environs de strasbourg à brumath les
cours d'eau ont quitté leur lit pour se
répandre jusqu'au centre de la ville
près de sarrebourg une voie ferrée est
inutilisable
a strasbourg même on frise parfois
l'inondation cela n'était pas arrivé
depuis 15 ans plus au sud vers sélestat
des eaux ont envahi les jardins publics
et les rues inondées ne permettent plus
la circulation des automobiles souvent
le niveau de l'eau atteint celui des
crues de 1947 et 1948 provoquant
éboulements ou glissements de terrain
dans la région de colmar la fecht a
cessé de monter mais les hauts de l'île
continue de s'enfler submergeant le port
et la zone industrielle le sinistre ne
respectent même pas les cimetières
militaires partout les pompiers sont sur
la brèche
plus au sud encore à ta nea mulhouse
l'eau a envahi les routes dans la région
de guebwiller la situation ne cesse
d'empirer à merxheim un tronc d'arbre
charge charrier parle alors à en porter
le tablier d'un pont que le génie rural
s'efforce à présent de préserver d'une
destruction totale
loi des séries ou coïncidence dramatique
hier soir à marseille où une explosion a
fait quatre morts et 12 blessés dans une
nuit j'ai ri le bilan sera peut être
plus lourd car une cinquième personne
est portée disparue la catastrophe a été
évitée de justesse l'huilerie possédait
une réserve de 80 mille litres d'essence
les bâtiments voisins ont été endommagés
parmi eux le dépôt des autobus et
l'immeuble notre confrère le provençal
mais nous avons nos correspondants de
marseille en direct
alors attention à vous marçais
quatre morts 12 blessés 4 millions de
francs de dégâts tel est le bilan de
l'explosion et de l'incendié qui ont
ravagé hier à marseille vers 19h35
avenue roger salengro une huilerie qui
emploie 170 personnes si l'on ignore
actuellement les causes de ce sinistre
l'on sait cependant que l'explosion a eu
lieu dans la salle extraction lusine
cette salle était essentiellement
équiper le condensateur et de distillers
qui était placée sous pression au moment
de l'explosion qui a été perçu à
plusieurs kilomètres quatre hommes se
trouvaient dans la salle extraction hier
soir vers 22h30 l'on devait retirer les
décombres le premier cadavre
ce matin le deuxième les deux autres ont
été aperçues sous les amas de tôles et
de béton ils seront retirés probablement
aujourd'hui en début d'après midi
autre souci des sauveteurs enrayer la
panique qui avait gagné certains et
préserver les huit cuves d'essence
contenant près de cent mille litres qui
se trouvait à quelques mètres de la
salle extraction une partie du quartier
avaient été évacuées
d'ailleurs l'explosion a endommagé de
nombreux appartements et des magasins
situés à une centaine de mètres de
l'usiné
actuellement il n'y a plus aucun risque
et l'explosion et l'incendié totalement
circonscrit ce sinistre pour cependant
une fois de plus le problème de
l'implantation en plein centre d'une
ville du sinn traitant des produits
inflammables
jean-michel leniaud la page sportive de
ce journal nous conduit à val gardena
encore une fois où l'équipe de france
féminine de ski disputée ce matin la
descente surprend mais exactement c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité sportive
pendriez bon de rappeler quand même le
bon résultat obtenu par vichy hyères qui
en coupe d'europe des coupes en basket a
réussi le match nul face au standard de
liège est donc en ski surprise car il ya
eu des chutes et pourtant il n'ya pas
très souvent déchu parmi les 15
premières c'est à dire celle de la
première série en ce qui concerne les
descentes des chutes survenues presque
toutes dans le premier tiers du parcours
et puis une surprise c'est une jeune
suissesse de 21 ans qui a gagné elle
s'appelle anne rose dribbler française
me direz-vous égard elles sont assez loi
sauf isabelle mir qu'à faire du 50
centièmes de seconde et qui est deuxième
troisième
anne marie paule l'autrichienne à deux
secondes 02 100e voyez que derrière mire
et grid est une
que des grands écarts quatrième crawford
la canadienne deux grandes 33 centièmes
5e ingrid grounder l'autrichienne à deux
secondes 68 centièmes et puis si vous
aimez les précisions je peux vous dire
que à près de trois secondes se trouve
cet horaire qui est 6e celle qui est
margaret a fait une allemande qui était
pourtant parti avec le dossard numéro 27
c'est un grand exploit à trois secondes
8e jacquot à presque 4 secondes 9e art
in cochrane et 10e olga en ce qui
concerne des chutes
judy nagl première victime elle était
partie avec le dossard numéro 3
l'américaine et c'était l'une des
prétendantes à la victoire
et puis françoise maquis partis un peu
plus tard en 8e position
et oui le truc bruxelles qui était la
grande favorite on peut le dire avec
isabelle mir et hier d'après les temps
réalisés à la londe stop semir qui avait
réussi le meilleur chrono
le deuxième temps avait été réussi par
rexel alors que the ride qui aujourd'hui
a triomphé était 4e à égalité tort ex
torres se dire qu'on ne peut pas
toujours tenir compte des temps réalisés
à la non stop
mais seulement il ya quand même sur la
carte de visite de hal rose reid qui a
gagné aujourd'hui une victoire
impressionnante qu'on avait peut-être
oublié ce matin c'est sa victoire l'an
dernier sur cette même piste à val
gardena pour la répétition des
championnats du monde je vous propose
maintenant puisque vous connaissez le
résultat de voir une descente sans trop
de commentaires celle de rides
la suissesse sont un nom difficile à
prononcer zrr y des ébats si elle vient
de franchir déjà les deux tiers du
parcours elle était alors prono mettrai
en 42 secondes 71 centièmes il faut dire
que la suisse a été la seule à descendre
en dessous de 43 centièmes 43 secondes
plus tôt pour ce premier tiers du parc
elle devançait déjà à isabelle mir de 66
centièmes de seconde
la piste était longue de 2750 mètres
trente et une porte de direction et 622
mètres de dénivellation vous allez voir
son temps s'inscrire le temps d'en haut
c'est celui réalisé par jaco de 0 2 et l
une 58,34 on a eu peur en menant et
l'impression qu'elle était tombée c'est
uniquement un nuage de neige ici à son
arrivée épuisée rythme va évidemment
être maintenant prédit cité par ses
camarades de l'équipe suisse c'est la
première victoire d'une suissesse dans
ces championnats du monde est encore une
des routes défoncées espérons qu'elle se
rattraperont demain ou si bien les
français que la france est dans le style
spécial pour les féminines et dans la
descente dimanche pour les messieurs
jeanpierre merci le conseil des
ministres s'est réuni ce matin à 10
heures au palais de l'elysée sous la
présidence de monsieur georges pompidou
deux absents à ce conseil le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur raymond marcellin
et le secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et
aux sports monsieur committee qui vous
savez sont en ce moment même à val
d'isère
le conseil s'est terminé très exactement
à 12h30 nouvelle université ans le
centre assas de la faculté de droit et
des sciences économiques de paris est
fermé aujourd'hui la suspension des
enseignements théoriques et pratiques
dure depuis maintenant 48 heures elle
est consécutive je vous le rappelle aux
incidents qui ont opposé lundi après
midi des étudiants appartenant à des
formations politiques rivales dernière
journée de la visite officielle en
france du ministre espagnol des affaires
étrangères monsieur lopez bravo avant
son départ ce soir 20 heures de
l'aéroport du bourget le ministre
espagnol sera reçu cet après midi au
palais de l'elysée par le président
pompidou
je vous rappelle que ce voyage a été
marquée par la signature d'un accord un
accord portant sur la livraison de 30
mirage 3 e à l'espagne un accord donc
qui intéressent les deux p nouvelles de
l'étranger le chef de l'état libyen le
colonel kadhafi est arrivé la nuit
dernière au caire il s'entretiendra dans
la capitale égyptienne avec le président
nasser et avec le chef de l'état
soudanais le général ni mirent toute la
presse britannique commandes ce matin
les conclusions du livre blanc sur
l'entrée de la grande-bretagne dans le
marché commun nos contrats britanniques
s'attache particulièrement au fardeau
financier qui pèsera je cite sur le
panier de la ménagère britannique et je
vous signale que l'entrée de la
grande-bretagne dans le marché commun
étaient évalués par des spécialistes
entre 100 millions et un milliard de
livres sterling autre réaction de la
presse étrangère celle de la presse
allemande
après l'attentât qui a fait un mort et
12 blessés hier à l'aéroport iem demi
la presse d'outre-rhin salem en général
contre tous les attentats perpétrés en
europe contre les avions israéliens
depuis plus d'un an et un journal
munichois écrit notamment la république
fédérale reste neutre dans le conflit
israélo arabe mais si l'un des deux
belligérants cherche à commettre sur
notre territoire des actes de violence
nous devrons réagir contre lui avec la
dernière détermination informations
générales le japon vient d'entrer dans
le club spatiale après quatre échecs en
1966 1967 et 1969
les techniciens japonais ont réussi ce
matin à lancer un satellite artificiel
de 23 kg quelques instants après son
lancement le satellite était
correctement placée en nos dernières
informations générales le premier
turbotrain sera présentée officiellement
demain 12 février en gare de pau un
voyage de démonstration aura lieu demain
après-midi entre pau et puyoô le tueur
breton je vous le rappel doit être
effectué son premier service commercial
16 mars prochain entre paris et caen
jacqueline alexandre je crois que les
femmes sont autorisées depuis quelques
temps officiellement entrée à la bourse
est certaine je crois s'intéressent même
à des opérations financières
effectivement et c'est pourquoi
cristiani lacroix s'est rendu dans un
club où les femmes apprennent comment on
fait des choses à la bourse et pour quoi
elle parle
investissement elle parle bourse nous
allons maintenant voir christiane de la
croix le sample de l'argent dont l'accès
jusqu'à ces dernières années était
interdit aux femmes aujourd'hui elles
deviennent de plus en plus nombreuses
sous les rafales d'offre et de demande
elle suivit cote des valeurs mobilières
et s'intéresse à leur tour aux
principaux composants de l'économie
française à vie moderne formule moderne
pour investir son épargne gardienne des
économies du ménage elles s'inscrivent
dans des clubs d'investissement féminin
qui se multiplient tant à paris qu'en
province
regardez avec nos versements mensuels de
100 francs
nous disposons maintenant de 1500 francs
investis nous pouvons voir dans quel
secteur il est préférable d'investir
oui après huit mois d'existence le
montant de notre portefeuille et de
12126 france qui se répartit en 84 % de
valeurs françaises et 19% valeurs
étrangères
alors est-ce que vous pensez que nous
devions nous accès actuellement vers les
valeurs étrangères ou alors continuer
dans les valeurs françaises par exemple
vers les chimie où nous sommes assez peu
le contrôle des changes
vassal chaque adhérente du club va
pouvoir donner son avis d'après ces
sources personnelles d'information ses
lectures ses études de marché alors le
secteur quelque chose le génie chimique
dans le compartiment d'alchimie nous
avons donc choisi de prendre un
laboratoire pharmaceutique
alors qui est pour le laboratoire qui
compte 2 alors 13 pour et 2 contre la
majorité des deux tiers requise
nous prenons à laboratoire vous avez
adhéré très vite à ce club dont un est
mort pourquoi parce que les problèmes
économiques nous sommes toujours
intéressés
j'ai trouvé là une raison de participer
à une vie dans laquelle je ne suis pas
directement impliquée parce qu' elle ne
me concerne pas je n'exerçais pas de
profession je suis veuve je travaille et
je suis venu dans ce club pour apprendre
pour apprendre de courts déplacements je
considère la bourse comme une forme
d'état âme vivante et c'est ce qui m'a
intéressé scientifique et auch est
effectivement j'aime ça et j'aimerais
même voir plus loin
c'est à dire pouvoir un jour me
constituer un portefeuille et jouent en
bourse salle investir en bourse
qu'est ce que cela signifie peau
c'est bien ça me donne l'occasion de
s'intéresser aux problèmes financiers
que jusque là je connaissais très peu
par exemple en lisant les journaux tout
le temps je rencontre les termes de
valeurs mobilières de marché à terme
marché au comptant
jusque là vraiment pour moi session très
très vague et
si vous voulez je veux être perfectionne
là dedans je m'initie et toutes ces
questions et tout cas l'heure actuelle
c'est actuellement nécessaire elle est
artiste peintre et graveur
elle s'intéresse aux problèmes boursiers
pourquoi quelques problèmes dans ma vie
j'en ai eu beaucoup oui et c'est
justement un peu à cause de ça que je me
suis intéressé à la bourse c'est parce
que j'avais un petit capital hérité de
mon père qui finalement a fondu
effroyablement je me suis demandé
pourquoi j'ai pensé que je pourrais
peut-être avec un peu d'orgueil enfin
j'ai pensé que je pourrais essayer de
faire mieux que simplement laisser
courir les choses c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle j'ai voulu faire partie
d'un club
j'aime aussi savoir comment une valeur
se raccorde à une autre dans un groupe
et c'est ça qui justement est
intéressant dans l' architecture de
l'économie du pays
parce qu'on sait par exemple ce qui
structure la sidérurgie ce qui va
constituer les groupes de chimie
ce qui est très important dans les
pétrole etc etc
madame vous exercer le métier d'assureur
oui je suis revenu en prévoyant si on
retraite je rencontre des personnes qui
sont intéressées par les problèmes de
sécurité et de placement vous n'avez pas
toujours travaillé non absolument pas
mais je me suis retrouvée veuve très
jeune j'avais 28 ans et j'avais deux
enfants alors je me suis trouvé bien
entendu dans l'obligation de travailler
que vous apporte cette appartenance à ce
club d'investissement sur le plan
personnel et sur le plan professionnel
sur le plan personnel j'ai considéré le
club d'investissement comme une école de
formation qui déjà actuellement mais
encore plus certainement dans l'avenir
me permettra de d'épargné d'une façon et
productive et non pas et stagnante
d'autre part sur le plan professionnel
et bien mon dieu c'est une formule
d'investissement comme une autre et par
conséquent je me devais de la connaître
un fonds pour pouvoir en parler et
comparer avec d'autres formules de
placement
avec les personnes que je rencontre une
question je voudrais poser la présidente
pourquoi avoir créé des clubs
essentiellement féminin il ya
l'investissement bon ce n'est pas une
occupation typiquement féminine je crois
que quand les femmes sont entre elles
elles ont beaucoup plus d'audace et elle
use et s'exprimer il ya des tas de
choses qu'elle ne ferait pas comment qui
sont ces nouvelles femmes de valeur
eh bien ces femmes de valeur avec
beaucoup d'elle parce que nous avons
beaucoup espérons avoir beaucoup ces
femmes de valeur viennent de tous les
horizons sont des mères de famille ou
bien des femmes qui travaillent ou même
éventuellement des étudiants tout en
tout cas concernés par l'économie qui
ont envie de découvrir et de faire des
travaux pratiques avec nous vous
réunissez une fois par mois nous nous
réunissons une fois par mois pendant
deux heures dansant un versement de 100
francs
et avec ses 1500 francs puisque nous
sommes 15 millions d investissements
prévoir en bourse est un art véritable
une oasis en étudiant à rennes il faut
faire appel à quelqu'un oui nous avons
un agent de change qui nous aide qui
nous soutiennent apporte ses conseils
mais qu'en pensent les hommes à la
bourse
monsieur meunier en tant que syndic de
la compagnie des agents de change
pourriez vous nous dire à quel moment
ces clubs font appel eh bien madame ils
font appel à nous je dirais presque je
le souhaiterais en permanence carmes
vis-à-vis de nounous vont jouer un rôle
de guide et de conseillers c'est bien
évident car surtout au début de ces
clubs ils en ont besoin par conséquent
ce rôle nous le jouons nous en tant qu
agent de change
les banquiers car il ya également des
clubs qui ont ouvert des comptes chez
les banquiers ces clubs par conséquent
peuvent trouver auprès de tous ceux
qu'il souhaite et je dirais presque un
petit peu à certains côtés par assurons
nos si ce n'est pas trop prétentieux de
le dire je peux dire également que nous
avons à leur disposition tout un centre
de documentation qui fonctionne
dans notre chambre syndicale et pour eux
c'est très utile car ils peuvent venir
celui que monter et par conséquent ceux
ci ajoute à tous les conseils qui
peuvent recueillir auprès de vous croyez
au club d'investissement féminin les
femmes en un bon jugement et bien madame
oui je crois au club féminin je crois
que le féminin car je crois que les
femmes dans beaucoup de domaines
d'ailleurs quand elles prennent quelque
chose à coeur le fond très sérieusement
peut-être même plus que les hommes
les sommes engagées par ces clubs sont
assez réduites en fait qu'est-ce que ces
clubs peuvent apporter à la bourse bien
ils peuvent apporter beaucoup ils
peuvent apporter beaucoup parce que si
par leur canal il y à un développement
de l'actionnariat en france à l'instar
de ce qui s'est passé dans les villes
trangé ceci le peut-être que très bon
pour le marché financier et par
conséquent excellent pour l'économie
générale française bien si vous
intéresser aux transactions boursières
nous allons retrouver le réalisateur de
ce passage jean roch qui est maintenant
la bourse de paris avoue jean roch avoue
gérard vidal anges